[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde bonne année et quoi
de mieux pour commencer cette nouvelle
année qu'un petit hors sujet et ce
coup-ci on va aborder quelque chose qui
n'est jamais sorti en France du moins
jusqu'à très récemment les dramas après
dire drama c'est un abus de langage un
drama ça signifie dramatique parce que
très souvent les dramas japonais sont
des drames des drames sentimentaux des
drames scolaires ici on devrait plutôt
parler de live action alors un live
action c'est quoi et bien c'est tout
simplement l'adaptation avec des vrais
acteurs de quelque chose ayant déjà
existé en animé alors des dramas il y en
a plein parfois ça passe plutôt bien
comme GTO notamment parce que la série
est relativement réaliste à la base des
fois c'est plutôt bien adapté comme
radem demi mais des fois tu te demandes
comment ils vont faire et je veux dire
tenez prenez Juliet je t'aime en animé
ça passe ah quelle heure il est on s'est
bien amusé mais pourquoi tu veux pas te
relaxer un peu et puis t'amuser avec
nous ça détend la préparateur tu veux
boire un petit coup de jus et mais en
vraiette
à la porion des mimosas tout le monde
est singlé il y a déjà qure personnes
qui se sont
suicid les HLM les HLM vas-y viens faut
qu'on bar d'ici alors maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça donne quand on prend
l'adaptation d'une série où tout le
monde se prend au sérieux et qui en même
temps est complètement irréaliste genre
[Musique]
ça et bien allons
voir sert à rien donc pr of tennis sorti
en 2006 tiré de la série du même nom on
retrouve donc le héros qui rentre tout
juste des États-Unis et qui prend le
train qui le mène jusqu'à Tokyo à
l'intérieur une
bandeaca de tennis comme par hasard les
et embête une jeune fille muette
elle a dit kodasa ça veut dire arrêter
s'il vous plaît tu parles japonais
non évidemment le jeune héros intervient
et F un
[Applaudissements]
tennis vous savez je suis curieux de
savoir comment ça se passe parce que
dans tous les animés c'est un peu pareil
c'est genre viens je te défie allez
vas-y montre-moi ce que tu sais faire et
cetera alors bon quand c'est une partie
de toupie ça se fait sur le tas ça va
mais là c'est du tennis quand même c'est
un peu plus complexe oui bonjour en fait
je vous explique j'étais en train donc
d'agresser une Zune handicapée puis
après il y a un enfant qui s'est
interposéfin bon je vous passe les
détails mais du coup en fait on cherche
un cours de libre c'est pour une
vengeance et puis même il se serait
passé quoi si ça avait pas été des
racailles de tennis vous laissez-la
tranquille je vous défie au tennis
tant pis
désolé bref après avoir battu les
racailles du tennis etizen c'est son nom
arrivve au cours de tennis de son lycée
et commence à battre son sempai sous le
regard du groupe de Kpop
local groupe qui est en fait le reste de
l'équipe mais finalement le match se
fait interrompre par le capitaine du
club tedzuka et j'ai pas pour habitude
de critiquer les acteurs mais vraiment
ce mec n'a qu'un seul regard pendant
tout le film et on dirait qu'il te dit
je comprends rien du tout à ce jeu
malgré son jeune âge eten est donc
sélectionné pour jouer dans l'équipe
alors que c'est contre les règles du
coup tout ce petit monde se dirige vers
une compétition amicale avec un autre
lycée local c'est l'équipe du lic voisin
qui arrive pour le match et tu as tout
le poulailler qui est là pour
[Applaudissements]
l'accueillir non mais dis donc tu
pourraas au moins ranger tes affaires
c'est vraiment le bordel et la vaisselle
pourquoi c'est tout le temps moi qui
doit faire la
vaiss non mais dis donc est espèce de
gros connard tu crois que j'allais
fermer ma gueule hein et donc etizen
commence son premier
match allez c'est bon c'est le héros on
sait qu'il est plus fort que tout le
monde on sait qu'il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
va bon ok ça je l'ai rajouté en vrai il
se crève un œil et il reprend le match
ENF bon cela dit je veux bien qu'on so
dans une adaptation d'animé mais moi je
suis le capitaine je le fais sortir hein
parce qu'on est quand même au premier
point du premier
set regardez-moi les nul je vais vous
apprendre comment on jouer au
foot oh je me suis pété la jambe
je me suis pété la jambe bref pendant ce
temps-là dans l'ombre de la nuit
s'entraîne vous êtes sûr que tout le
monde a bien compris que c'est le
méchant de l'épisode on pourrait pas
rendre ça plus évident
encore malheureusement devant la future
compétition qui s'annonce tzuka le
capitaine de l'équipe ne peut plus jouer
car son célèbre
cool en français le rever du droit va
aggraver ses blessures et donc il n plus
le droit de le pratiquer SAF en cas de
climax scénaristique bonjour j'ai un
cliché pour monsur
grenier le destin du club tout entier va
donc reposer sur
la grande compétition de tennis commence
donc avec directement en ouverture le
match contre y l'équipe la plus
[Musique]
forte quoi vous avez jamais vu un match
de tennisf malgré leur super Cabrio
l'équipe commence mal et n'arrive pas à
dominer le match donc il décide de
changer de stratégie et de jouer
normalement et là et ben il perd quand
même alors je vais vous passer sur les
détails des matchs on a les tirs brossés
on a le ner qui calcule tout on a les
téléportations les balles enflammé mais
bon mon petit préféré à moi c'est
[Musique]
celui-là et l'arbitre qui s'arrête de
compter à 30 du premier set parce que
bon qu'est-ce que tu veux faire face à
ça
[Musique]
c'est sur lui qui fallait faire le film
moi je m'en branle du petit con là qui
s'est crevé un il en plus c'est un
connard moi c'est lui que je veux
voir plus il est tellement beau bon
finalement la compétition avance des
fois les gentil gag des fois les
méchants gagnent et donc on arrive et
c'est monsieur clacm qui
[Applaudissements]
revient ça marche dans les deux sens ça
marche dans les deux
sens C homme est un héros il affronte
tedzuka le capitaine de Seigaku mais qui
évidemment à cause de sa blessure craque
et doit arrêter le match alors bon
pourtant il a quand même un de
pouvoir de télékinésie qui attire les
balles je veux dire les autres font des
trucs de ouf en touchant les balles lui
il a même pas besoin de les toucher
évidemment du coup tout repose Suren
pour finir et gagner la compétition
contre le méchant c'est celui qui hurl
sous la lune donc après un bref échange
o il s'aperçoit quand même de la force
décide donc de passer à la puissance
[Applaudissements]
maximale
regardez tir de pirate mais qui c'est
qui est méchant mais méchant le
méchant le méchant
oui c'est lui c'est le
méchant il s'habille tout en noir c'est
un méchant est-ce que vous avez
compris ça arrive tous les jours en
Bretagne évidemment vu que c'est le
méchant il commence à essayer de casser
les jambes de l'adversaire alors
excusez-moi j'étais en train de de
consulter les Règles et en fait
alors tirer dans le public ah ça c'est
bon on a le droit non mais c'est bon on
va appeler les cufs là c'est une prise
d'otage c'est plus un match finalement
se relève et son genou se répare tout
seul parce
que Japon et réussi à gagner le match
grâce et ben au
tennis comme desnom non parce que en
gros les 10 dernières minutes du film
c'est ça
ok mais SS ont le pouvoir de contrôler
les planètes et la force du vent
pourquoi est-ce que ça finit comme du
tennis comme si les combats dans des B
finiss judo
mais et voilà céit pr ten juste une
petite pensée pour les ramasseurs de
ball finalement j'aime bien ce film je
trouveètement con mais dans le bon sens
du terme c'est vraiutant dans er par
exemple c'est n'importe quoi assumer
c'est une comédie au temps là les mecs
se prennent tout super au sérieux et du
coup ça donne cet effet très con et en
même temps très marrant maintenant le
film il est aidé quand même il y a des
moyens il y a du budget dans les effets
spéciaux du coup on va aller voir ce que
ça donne la même chose mais sans pognon
c'est parti pour sailor moon on commence
donc par un beau soir de Noël et par une
jeune fille qui chante au
balcon très mal quand soudain une
peluche tombe du ciel et se met lui
parler
[Musique]
est-ce que quelqu'un a vu l'argent le CH
lui donne donc un téléphone portable du
PL de la dessus et la voil transformé en
guerrière de la
[Musique]
lune écoute la peluch qui parle
[Applaudissements]
aucune question à se
poser et donc sans attendre avec ses
nouveaux pouvoirs elle décide d'aller
arrêter un voleur
rose blanc et après un bref combat et
c'était blanc finalement réussi à
[Musique]
gagner on est à 5 minutes 45 de
l'épisode 1 de la saison 1 on serait à
l'épisode 18 de la saison 9 je
comprendrai la lassitude et cetera mais
là je peux pas m'empêcher d'imaginer les
mecs de l'équipe technique qui font ça
allez on la garde et on commence
l'histoire donc chez buni en français
qui s'appelle Uzagi en japonais
et qu'est-ce que tu bouffes remarque
s'il bouffe de la peinture ça explique
pourquoi ils peuvent parler aux peluches
bref c'est exactement comme dans l'animé
oagi donc est le cliché de la fille tête
en l'air mais qui est pleine de joie de
vivre et au passage je vais m'attarder
que sur le scénario je parlerai pas des
choix étranges du réalisateur qui des
fois a l'air de se dire tiens là je vais
mettre un fich sans aucune raison fait
bon donc il se trouve que en ce moment
la ville subit une vague de crime et
donc agi et ses amis décident de se
déguiser en SV la fille du début pour
essayer de capturer le voleur ça aurait
été drôlement plus efficace de se
déguiser en flic mais bon allez passons
sauf que le problème c'est que les
méchantes sont déjà
là ok ont un blouson en cuir et une moto
mais quand même il manque une éclipse
mais la vraie C avec son champ en
peluche ainsi que Bourdu l'homme masqué
veille depuis l'toit oh mais
regardez la tristesse de ce plan
et là je crois qu'on atteint vraiment la
limite du livetion parce que vous voyez
autant pren s tennis même s'ils ont des
super pouvoirs ça reste des mecs qui
joue au tennis ça passe mais là par
contre la différence animée réelle elle
se fait vraiment ressentir oh mon dieu
BOURD masqué il est trop classe ah non
regardez un fou va sauter du toit pe
presque imaginer le mec repartir en bus
chez lui après donc les méchantes
s'introduisent dans le musée pour le
cambriolet mais Uzagi et ses amis
interviennent or les méchantes prennent
les copines d'uzagi pour des alliés de
la vraie c'est leur V et donc décide de
les capturer et évidemment elles ne font
pas le poids face à T de confetti bref
donc Uzagi arrive avec un extincteur
pour les sauver
[Applaudissements]
et waouh c'était le truc le plus
efficace que j'ai vu depuis le début de
cette série c'est comme ça que devrait
être les magical girl tu as été méchant
alors au nom de la lune je vais te
butter finalement les méchants ramèent
agi à leur repère parce qu'elle a avalé
la clé d'un coffre fort et puis font un
tour de magie
[Musique]
ok ok la boîte oui très
bien qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train de
faire et au moment où le méchant
va pour la tuer la vraie C arrive et
s'ens la bataille la plus pourri que
j'ai jamais
vu attention mon plastique FL Ahou mér
mettre la scène au ralenti quand même
qu'on arrive à suivre l'action vous
savez
ok sinon tu veux pas lâcher ton
avé lâche ce
truc lâche ce
truc les méchants ont été arrêtés
l'épisode est terminé lâche ce truc
qu'est-ce que tu vas en faire de toute
façon non répondez pas bon bref donc
l'épisode se termine sur un affrontement
entre Bourdu et sorv et Luna qui arrive
sur Terre
r dans l'Atos
merde heureusementun est deén 3400 km
renontre qui
fut
d'habitardéle ny la CL en punition mais
heusement
copineer non Uzagi et Narou vont donc
voir après la mère de Narou une
organisatrice de défilé de mode qui
organise un gros défilé pour le
lendemain Narou propose alors à sa mère
de lui ramener un sandwich le lendemain
sans savoir que des méchantes tentacules
ont envahi
l'endroit le lendemain donc qu' prévu
Narou retourne voir sa mère mais
celle-ci a oublié que la veille sa fille
devait lui porter un sandwich et donc en
tire la conclusion parfaitement logique
qu'un démon est venu sur terre et a pris
possession du corps de sa
mère bien vu bien
joué et ça évidemment ça peut pas être
juste parce qu'elle a oublié ou parce
qu'elle s'en bat les couilles parce
qu'elle a un gros défilé dans une heure
non non donc ou c'est la meilleure
détective du monde ou alors elle est
complètement parano o j'ai foutu
mes clés j'ai
[Musique]
oublié paniqué Narou s'enfuit et demande
l'aide à un balayeur qui passa par là et
qui en fait se révèle
être pendant ce tempsl Luna dont le
budget d'animation 3D a l'air de varier
autant que le cours de la bourse révèle
à agi qu'elle Moon et lui donne son
attirail de guerrière de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lune oui je te rappelle je suis en
tournage et agi grâce à son nouvel
équipement le voir de l'ennemi bon alors
on va pas tous les faire dans le 3è
épisode c'est comme dans le dessin animé
rencontre midzuno Molly en français qui
deviendra c'est leur
Mercury autant je craquais sur elle dans
le dessin animé autant là je me sens
sale
diamant et ainsi de suite après c'est
Mars Jupiter et cetera bon la série a un
certain charme c'est vrai mais je pense
qu'il faut vraiment être un fan hardcore
du dessin animés pour pouvoir apprécier
la série après bon c'est vrai que c'est
un certain charme amateur en quelque
sorte mais vu que la série n'est pas
amateur je suis pas sûr que ça soit un
compliment sachez d'ailleurs que
évidemment ces séries sont très souvent
des prétextes pour faire des spectacles
alors autant j'ai pas été étonné de voir
cur Moon puisqueaès tout c'est le Vénus
c'est une chanteuse donc c'est legit
mais Prin of
[Musique]
tennis et c'est ce jourl les enfants
qu'on a inventé le playback et ça
s'arrête pas là des Comé musical je
crois qu'il en a peu près sur tous les
animés possibles
u envie de voir par ça l' vraiment cool
et même des trucs plus vieux
genre ouis ouais c'est je crois que
c'est une servante du manoir
d'Ath visiblement c'est un peu le manoir
Mar Dorsel che bref voilà cet épisode
est terminé alors finalement les dramas
et plus particulièrement ici les live
action tiré d'animé moi j'y vois juste
une contra supplémentaire pas forcément
utile qu'on s'impose quelque chose qui
serait facile à faire en animé devient
dur à faire et ce qui est mignon devient
Glo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh même au niveau des looks je veux dire
regardez madame de Saint Fiacre dans
l'URA et la passion du théâtre bon dans
le dessin animé ça va j'accepte son look
mais là franchement on dirait un
seigneur
s alors est-ce que j'aime ça et ben je
sais pas finalement j'ai l'impression de
passer mon temps à chercher les
références que j'ai déjà vu dans l'animé
genre ah oui ça c'est comme dans l'animé
ah oui ça c'est comme dans l'animé
finalement j'ai envie de te dire du coup
tu as regardé
l'animé mon Dieu c'était donc aussi
simple
[Musique]